we literally recreated the fastest cars
on the planet in gta everything from a
300 mile per hour car to a 500 mile
power car to the fastest car in the
world that is 3 000 miles per hour
that's a lot of miles and we're gonna be
racing them all on complex tracks and
whoever comes in last place has to take
a bath in ketchup you know i hate
ketchup three
two
one go
let's go
oh cool i get spun out in the beginning
yes i'm in the back because of chandler
just you guys know first place gets four
points second gets three third gets one
last place gets zero overheads elise
bates and ketchup ow oh no
so i just won't get last perfect
whoa see you later red car dimwit
oh my god it takes so long for the lambo
to flip back oh just flip over hey chris
chris how does the last place feel this
is so annoying carl i'm coming for you
does that make me first
nope not anymore
holy
oh no no no no no i'm in first i'm at
first well i went from first to third oh
dude there's so many cards
hi jimmy ow oh i'm embarrassed again
let's go
lovely my game crashed that's good
because i didn't think i was going to
catch up
way our finish yeah
for race number two you're all in semi
trucks currently chandler has three carl
has two chris has one and i get a
sympathy point for my game crashing are
you ready i'm semi-ready
this time if i don't disconnect you're
all done for
fun
get faster loser
now i'm on my side i'm in last i got to
catch up
oh my god oh my god if you hit the cars
they'll send you flying no i just hit
the cars you guys are fine don't worry
well it's because you're going 500 miles
an hour
oh my gosh there's limousines
oh my god this course is so cool it's a
giant football field wow i love this
course what the heck this is epic
everything you see we custom built i
can't wait to see whatever you guys are
seeing
there's a bowling alley guys chris you
want to allow me to catch up i'll allow
you to catch up when you get into the
bathtub full of ketchup oh volleyball
i passed jimmy i bought with a strike
i've already falled i don't want to sit
catcher
i've lived my whole life driving trucks
and it's paid off for this moment right
now no i can't get catch up
whoa
first place what part are you on
chandler i've got to be close oh wait
jimmy you want to know what part i'm in
the finish line come on i gotta finish
start i gotta finish third i'm waiting
right here if anybody hits me it's their
fault to be clear i allow it because i'm
bald i'll also get in an inconvenient
spot
see ya
uh jimmy whoa
baby i just skirted past you for once
jimmy now you're a loser and your ball
chris now has four points carl has four
points chandler has four points and i
have one that you gave yourself this is
a massive mountain and we're gonna race
these insane monster trucks to the top
start the timer oh my god we're flying
with the semi trucks you could only go
500 miles an hour now you can go 750
you're rubber banding oh drink
oh
oh we ought to ran into the wall bro my
car will go back forward go forward you
stupid car chris you just have to not
lose i'm in first guys i mean you're
giving me the win cool cool
next two giant rocks block i can't get
past the rocks hey chris chris that's
what you get i literally think i'm
driving on butter i don't know what's
happening i'm pretty sure it's a
mountain not butter
okay okay
oh bye chandler i'll catch you later
dude
oh [ __ ] i hate you bro
thank you i'm in first give me the zero
points i'm just gonna give up
about the finish but there's a freaking
rock in front of me go
i did it
yeah
hey i didn't get last first didn't get a
point i got one carl and trailer got
their stupid points next race
for this next map we're all driving
teslas but they're custom modded to
drive a thousand miles an hour that's a
lot of miles servers start the countdown
i just want to warn you guys a thousand
miles an hour is very fast put on your
seat belts baby
so cars are going so fast now it's
probably gonna rubber band a little bit
on your screen because we're literally
breaking gta i don't see a rubber band
just a lot of minecraft stuff so behind
already
festivals
chocolate
oh no carl keeps flying past me and then
having to reset yes yes crash keep
crashing keep crashing among us in the
distance oh god these guys are looking
kind of sus over here
oh shoot i just got caught red-headed
carl stop just flying down the map i
have a need for speed baby oh nope oh
bye jimmy all right well i'm gonna get
dead last i'm going super speed
mr beast is this the end
this next map we're going to be racing
tesla cyber trucks down this giant ramp
whoever jumps the highest wins as of
right now two of you have eight points
chris has seven and i'm in dead last
sounds like you're getting in catch up
and you're bald start the timer they're
mean i'm gonna start as high as possible
who blew up
here we go i need to hit 1500 miles an
hour
i'm going you lit i'm going a thousand
i'm still going up how am i still going
up keep climbing i'm on four thousand
oh my god i just started going back down
[Music]
oh chris beat me keep going
how how did you guys fly higher than me
i got third i got second again i'm not
taking a ketchup bath
i again didn't get points i think you
have to try doing better next race so i
think it's pretty obvious to everyone
you're a loser and you're bald i'm gonna
have to sit and catch up i think it's
time one of you join me whoever comes
second to last now has to bathe and
catch up let's see who's joining me
chris for carl not me
i cool i start off with getting split
out oh by the way the cars can go 2 000
miles an hour now
you can't even drive this thing dude
look at the fries that i'm not gonna
touch because i don't want ketchup
either dave why is it when i'm not
trying i do better
i hit that so hard look at that massive
gas why is there so much minecraft we're
literally playing gta
i just hit it i don't i don't understand
i thought you're good at gta
please get second dude i'm in first is
there like turns or is it all just
straightaways uh i don't know but i do
know that i just got first
yeah
i don't want no ketchup
i did it
yeah it's no ketchup for me
wow and chris if you get first in the
next one you don't have to do the
ketchup i gotta try i hate ketchup so
much i hate the smell of it i hate the
taste of it for this final map we're
gonna be in the fastest cars ever made
this thing literally goes 3000 miles per
hour and we're gonna take turns to see
who can launch the highest off the ramp
start the timer two
makes you go higher right now
okay one two three zero seven twelve
thousand three hundred and seven meters
chris is next let's do this three two
one go
all right can he hit three thousand
oh can i get her straight get her
straight oh it's so hard to keep it
short did you even boost gib you have to
beat my number we're still going we're
still going please stop oh he slowed
down what all right wait why did i stop
at 9 500. here we go
oh my gosh how do you aim to stick
oh my god he's an elephant oh i figured
it out baby oh this is gonna be close
stop tumbling he might not make it
oh
barely
me and chris are officially in last
place i don't lose as promised we have a
sea of ketchup yolo
oh it's so slimy hop on in
we are now disgusting i hope you're
satisfied is this what you wanted